mesdames et messieurs bonjour et
bienvenue à l'entretien de france 24 à
nicosie la dernière capitale divisée
d'europe alors ici à chypre les sujets
sont nombreux tensions avec la turquie
relations avec la russie ou encore
l'immigration le président chypriote
nikos anastacia 10 a accepté de répondre
à nos questions monsieur le président
nicollin as a service bonjour l'île de
chypre est divisée depuis 1974 quand la
turquie a envahi le quart nord de l'île
depuis 48 ans des négociations en vue
d'une réunification sont en cours
seulement voilà nous sommes à un point
crucial tout est gelé votre négociateur
en chef a même démissionné la semaine
dernière la question est la suivante
monsieur le président à l'eau non vers
une définitive division des chiffres
after bout c'est un premier pas
important
il n'y a t'il pas mort je tiens à vous
remercier de l'opportunité que vous me
donnez de répondre à des questions
cruciales qui concerne la république de
chypre et son plein les chypriotes grecs
et turcs
surtout regard de l'invasion russe en
ukraine qui se fait avec exactement les
mêmes arguments utilisés par la turquie
pour envahir j -p il y a maintenant 48
heures on peut donc faire le parallèle
entre les actions de certains pays qui
veulent changer avec un révisionniste
prononcer la position géographique de
certains pays ou des faits liés à
l'histoire pour maintenant il est vrai
que du temps s'est écoulé depuis le
début des négociations de paix et le
temps n'est pas un allié dans ce cas
surtout qu'il n'ya pas de réel progrès
mais je tiens à vous dire que nous nous
sommes nous chypriote toujours battu
pour qu'une solution soit trouvée nous
avons accepté de reculer sur des points
importants ce qui était difficile à
accepter pour un peuple déjà blessé lui
prêter une unique les habitants vivaient
ensemble cohabiter dans des villes et
des villages avec l'invasion turque les
chypriotes turcs ont été contraints
d'être transféré dans le nord de lille
il est chip rio de grecs occupe dans le
sud la met à faire tourner je veux que
vous compreniez plus qu'un tiers de la
population ici
réfugié dans son propre pays
chypriote grecque qui ont tout quitté
leurs biens leur maison leur vie en
témoignent des puits nous avons fait de
nombreux efforts nous avons progressé
sur de nombreux chapitres mais à chaque
fois nous devions faire face un
comportement intransigeant de la part de
la turquie yann qui insiste encore
aujourd'hui pour être la seule garante
de la république de chypre et et des
chypriotes du rhône qui au même moment
dans les chypriotes turcs ont proposé
qu'il y ait une parité de voix dans les
décisions du gouvernement de la
fédération il serait éventuellement
former mais cela a été rejeté par la
turquie
concrètement cela signifie que la
minorité veut gouverner la majorité de
chiites le nouveau statut de l'île sera
ancien protectorat d'ankara pourquoi je
vous le dis parce que les faits sont là
depuis 1974 la démographie de la partie
nord occupée de chypre a changé des
milliers de colons tueur s'y sont
installés qui a trente cinq mille
soldats turcs complètement contrôlé par
la turquie la grande majorité des
chipies culture conteste l'islamisation
de cette partie de parce qu'ils ont une
autre mentalité on grandit différemment
de ses colons nous ne sommes pas ceux
qui ont inventé la doctrine de la patrie
bleus que prône le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan
c'est à dire la nouvelle carte de
géopolitique maritime de la turquie
ceci est clairement du révisionnisme si
tu ne vise pas uniquement chypre mais
aussi la grèce puisque la souveraineté
grecque en mer egée est aussi contestée
par cette idéologie lui habillé ainsi
que la libye la syrie dans une même
l'irak il y as mégalomanie de la turquie
qui croient à pouvoir tout gérer six
dans la région qui épie riches du monde
donc si je comprends bien vous accusez
la turquie d'être de mauvaise foi quelle
serait pour vous la solution la plus
réaliste et des jeunes qui dès qu'il
monte qui commence une fédération de
zone vie communautaire avec une égalité
politique comme ce qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité des voix à l'assemblée des
nations unies de gama sur décision du
conseil de sécurité
pour comprendre nous sommes tombés
d'accord pour toutes ces années de
négociations sur le partage du pouvoir
législatif et du pouvoir judiciaire
la composition du pouvoir exécutif et il
restait à régler le problème du
territoire et bien plié le sujet de la
gouvernance mais surtout surtout la
turquie voulait que chypre soit sous le
contrôle de lecture king imaginez si la
russie demandé à devenir garant de
l'ukraine c'est pareil
alors la turquie veut aussi une part des
hydrocarbures qui je trouve dans les
sous dans les fonds marins chypriote
apparemment grande quantité d'ailleurs
des forages vont recommencer notamment
avec la société française total est ce
que vous avez peur d'une réaction turque
monsieur le président c'est l'honneur du
bâtiment fils vide ici je veux croire
que ne feront pas face à ces tensions la
turquie remet en cause notre zone
économique exclusive et ne reconnaît
toujours pas la république de chypre
cela tous les chypriotes grecs mais
aussi les chypriotes turcs nous avons
proposé deux solutions à la turquie à
l'ue soit de saisir la cour
internationale de justice à la haye ou
de lancer un arbitrage basée sur le
droit international de la mer afin de
trouver la ligne séparatrice des zones
économiques exclusives
chaque partie il n'aura plus aucun
problème je veux espérer que la turquie
ne provoquera pas d'incident et ne
mettra pas en danger la paix dans la
région donc ce que vous laissez partager
avec la turquie ces hydrocarbures anh
kiev où on respecte ce que dit le droit
international pourquoi pas
nous sommes prêts sur la base des zones
économiques exclusives qui ont été
tracées par tous les pays voisins
l'egypte israël et le liban alors
passons à un autre sujet comme la guerre
nuque rennes notamment beaucoup de
regards se sont tournés depuis le début
de la guerre vers chypre pourquoi et
bien parce que oui certes chypre a
soutenu le peuple ukrainien mais aussi
les décisions l'union européenne pour
l'embargo contre la russie seulement
voilà il ya l'une des plus grandes
communautés de russes à chypre alors ce
ne sont pas tous des oligarques mais le
gouvernement votre gouvernement a
notamment était axé d'octroyer des visas
doré donc dès ce qu'on appelle des
golden visas à certains oligarques
quelle est votre réponse chaque séquence
choc à bord je veux mettre au clair que
chypre est une destination attirante
pour les retraités
ou les gens qui décident d'en faire un
centre d'affaires ont raison de sa
position géographique et de son climat
par exemple la communauté anglaise ici
dépasse les 60 mille personnes
comme tous ceux qui viennent de pays
tiers ils ont gardé leur nationalité
oui il y a effectivement aussi une
grande communauté de russes qui ne
dépasse pas les vingt mille personnes et
qui travaille sur l'énigme sur les
oligarques je veux vous dire que l'union
européenne a dressé une liste de 1300
oligarques publié à la guerre contre
l'ukraine sur ses 1300 personnes
seulement 8 détiennent un passeport
supprime
et j'ai demandé à ce qu'ils leur soient
retirés en obéissant à la ligne comme
unique de l'union européenne
concrètement sur les rues c'est ce que
vous allez faire comme en angleterre
vous avez avec leurs propriétés les
ventres et valider en commun à challans
vous savez nous avons une constitution
qui pour protéger les chypriotes grecs
et turcs de l'expropriation est un droit
communautaire il ya donc un problème ici
j'en parle beaucoup avec charlie shell
mais ce n'est pas aussi simple de
prendre ces dynamiques sur le dossier
migratoire pareil c'est une porte
d'entrée en europe chypre même si ça ne
fait pas votre il ne fait pas partie de
l'espace schengen concrètement est ce
que vous avez à vous allez améliorer les
conditions d'accueil des migrants et
elle a lieu ici
malheureusement la turquie manu pile le
réfugié comme l'ont fait les biélorusses
aujourd'hui ici le taux de demandeurs
d'asile et de 5% de la population alors
que dans les pays de premier accueil il
ne dépasse pas les 1 60
c'est une manipulation qui change la
démographie de la population et nous
procurent de gros problèmes tant pour
l'hébergement que pour le reste nous
faisons notre possible recevant de
l'aide de lieu mais ce qu'il faut ce
sont des mesures contre ces
manipulations merci beaucoup monsieur le
président le temps presse merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cet entretien rester sur
nos antennes pour plus d'un formation
[Musique]